the Joe Rogan experience do you think he
has a chance oh absolutely
Bernie Sanders you really do okay well
let me ask you absolutely I do now let
me ask you this who of the Democrats do
you foresee really beating him beating
Trump no no beating Bernie in the
primary mmm
well it's good question right it's a
very good question he's got a lot of
support for sure but Elizabeth Warren
seems to have a lot of support right now
- okay so that's your answer right
Elizabeth Warren yeah I would say well
Joe Biden's [ __ ] he's too old but old
in the wrong way
like his communication skills have
eroded he floods his words he looks
exhausted he looks like he's just
waiting for them to shut the door so he
can take a big deep breath sink into the
couch you know I'm saying oh I know
exactly what you're saying I feel
sometimes I feel bad because it appears
like he genuinely has cognitive decline
yeah well he does so I don't like to
make fun of it
but then when he goes out there in the
debate and he starts like angrily
ranting and he says you know we got to
play the record player at night make
sure the kids hear words like that made
less than no sense man what are you
doing you got to wrap it up did you know
that his people actually they have a
plan it's called like a limited exposure
or limited visibility campaign where Joe
they are literally like hiding him from
the public as much as possible well they
have to they have to as he's still close
to the lead right Oh in some polls he's
still leading
that is hilarity and here's the thing
and this is what I was going to get to
in relation to Bernie I call the support
for Biden default support so default
support is people who don't necessarily
follow politics that closely but they
might be a registered Democrat and their
ass hey who do you support in this one I
don't know who's running Oh bye nobody
was a VP of Obama sure yeah Biden why
not that's the kind of support I think
Joe Biden has where that is very very
likely to kind of dwindle away and we're
seeing it right now because when you
look at the fundraising numbers Bernie
is breaking all records when it comes to
individual donations even out raising
Trump and Trump's a beast on the
campaign trail he's nothing to mess
around with on the campaign trail but
he's even out raising Trump when it
comes to individual donations his ground
game is airtight he's got people
everywhere
making phone calls knocking on doors
getting involved and so he has basically
an endless well of in small individual
donor support and an army of people on
the ground whereas Joe Biden is doing so
bad that he went back on his pledge like
oh I won't take super PAC money now he's
saying well if somebody were to make a
super PAC in order to help me you know
what do you want me to tell you because
he raised nine million dollars in the
last quarter
Bernie raised thirty and Joe raised nine
so Bernie happy lucky politics I love
talking about politics that explaining
everything I know but you're so Bernie
happy
well yeah cuz Joe he's uh he's an
amazing candidate who's just trying to
get the us to have social democracy and
he's a guy who I know cuz his record
shows it he's gonna fight for all of us
even if you don't agree with him and
even if you dislike him I understand
that you might be somebody who's
right-leaning he's too far left for you
but what everybody has to say and they
know it's true is he's incredibly honest
and he's actually gonna fight for you
every step of the way yes no I think
you're right I'm and talking to him he's
a very sincere guy and I think a lot of
his policies I agree with I really
really agree with this whole the the
exoneration of student loan debt that
that to me is a giant factor in a lot of
poor decision making that a lot of young
people make because they're [ __ ]
because they have this massive debt
hanging over their head it's a huge
source of stress and I think it's a
rigged system
I think it's dirty it's a dirty system
yeah the Medicare for all I think is a
wonderful idea as long as you can seek
you know very talented orthopedic
surgeons if you got some money we need
something fixed can you always pick your
doctor you know because you got a
there's a certain incentive right that I
think that certain doctors have towards
excellence right and a lot of that
incentive is financial and they're the
the doctors that are the very best in
certain particular fields they want to
charge more money for their services and
I think that that should be okay that's
this one of the things that helps make
people more enthusiastic about
excellence it's its financial reward
it's a part of human nature no
absolutely and that's what one of the
things that people despise about the
concept of socialism is that it's going
to somehow or another by you know making
sure that no one makes any more money
than anybody else which is like the most
extreme
well that's like authoritarian communism
yes yes yes but that's some I don't
agree with that at all either and people
who I talked to who are my friends on
the left they don't agree with that at
all and one of the things that we get
most annoyed with is when there's like a
conflation people will look at the
former Soviet Union people will look at
Venezuela people will look at Cuba and
they'll go hey well there's that's what
you want and that's what they say to us
and whenever we respond oh man we're
talking about social democracy we're
talking about what they have in
Scandinavia there's usually no
substantive rebuttal to that right other
than to say and what's funny Joe is they
will take credit for those systems in
some ways so it depends if you talk to
Ben Shapiro on one day he might say no
no no Joe those systems are so good
because they're capitalists to an extent
okay and though if I fire back at Ben
and I go okay bent and let's implement
that style of capitalism he'll swish it
and say no no there's socialists oh we
can't do that
[Applause]